hey hello
i'm thinking about going to a bank
around here
and opening an account you want me to
come
i want to try by myself all right
i'm not really going to the bank that
was
just a cover story to get out of the
house
i am actually going to the hotel
because my daughters taylor and cassie
are here right now
i moved to mexico less than a week ago
and
i asked my daughters to fly in because
today
i am proposing to armando
i missed you so um raimondo has not no
clue
like yeah he's like good oh he's gonna
be so happy
he doesn't know exciting unfortunately
bryson and madison won't be able to make
it
but having my two daughters here is
beyond amazing
[Music]
actually you guys will probably be here
oh my gosh we're just gonna walk right
down onto there
yeah that'll be perfect
i've been waiting for this day for a
long time
when i came out in 1988 hiv aids
was running rampant and by the early 90s
80 percent of the people i knew were
dead
and it's hard because you like to go
back and talk to some of these people
that you came out with and tell them
the world's changed for the better
so this is actually a big deal i want my
daughters
to see the love between armando and i
first hand
then maybe they can understand even
better why i laughed
you